se abre la puerta de las misiones
totalmente privadas a la estación
espacial internacional
un grupo de cuatro personas
seleccionados por la empresa action
space pasará a la historia como el
primer equipo comercial que utilizará el
centro orbital para su propósito privado
como laboratorio la visión está
compuesta por tres hombres de negocios y
un astronauta retirado y es vista como
un importante avance en la expansión de
las empresas comerciales espaciales
estamos como en los primeros días de la
internet y ni siquiera hemos imaginado
todas las posibilidades todas las
capacidades que vamos a proporcionar en
el espacio and elvis salen y venderemos
a esa plataforma como servicio service
el equipo estará diez días en órbita y
realizará investigaciones sobre las
células madre cardíacas el cáncer el
envejecimiento del cerebro además de sus
actividades comerciales divina o novedad
when you get space ahora sabemos que
cuando vas al espacio hay un poco de
aceleración en el envejecimiento así que
estamos haciendo algunas investigaciones
clínicas y diciendo wow
si hay un poco de aceleración ya sabes
identificando lo que causa esa
aceleración y entendiendo eso podemos
retrasar el envejecimiento o incluso
detenerlo word y ven esto que el
lanzamiento fue posible gracias a una
labor conjunta entre acción facilitadora
de los asientos espaciales la nasa que
permitió el uso del centro espacial
kennedy para su despegue y spacex que
proporcionó al cohete impulsor falcón
line y la nave dragón